y
[Música]
el premio nobel de paz desmond tutu
falleció este domingo a los 90 años el
arzobispo emérito sudafricano es
considerado una de las figuras clave de
la lucha contra la opresión racista de
la parte
se cumple un mes desde que omicron fue
declarada variante de preocupación por
la organización mundial de la salud el
imparable avance del linaje dejó miles
de contagios en el mundo el sábado
francia registró por primera vez más de
100 mil casos diarios desde el inicio de
la pandemia
el comité de seguridad de jartúm capital
de sudán comunicó que las
multitudinarias protestas del sábado
contra la junta militar dejaron 58
policías heridos y también que la
jornada terminó con más de 100
arrestados los militares cortaron las
comunicaciones y lanzaron gases
lacrimógenos contra los manifestantes
buen día para todos bienvenidos a esta
emisión de noticias en france 24 soy
valentina torre sánchez iniciamos este
informativo con el fallecimiento de
desmon tutú el arzobispo emérito
sudafricano que murió a los 90 años en
1984 recibió el premio nobel de paz por
su incansable lucha contra la
segregación racial en su país además su
trayectoria estuvo marcada por una
constante defensa de los derechos
humanos entre ellos los de la comunidad
lgbt y la otan acción algo que le llevó
a desmarcarse en numerosas ocasiones de
los lineamientos eclesiásticos
conozcamos más de su historia en el
siguiente informe
uno de los activistas por los derechos
sociales más destacados del mundo y el
hombre que está detrás del sueño
sudafricano de una nación arcoiris
desmon tutú podría despertar a grandes
multitudes mientras predicaba su mensaje
de no violencia lideró la lucha contra
el apartheid en sudáfrica con sus
discursos y siguió manifestándose por la
liberación de los presos políticos
durante años después de que se ganara
esa batalla cuando el líder del
movimiento de conciencia negra steve
biko fue asesinado por la policía en
1977 desmon tutú pronunció el sermón
fúnebre huelin
hannes waimer riesgo bastante cuando
dije lo de todos seremos libres un día
negros y blancos y añadí repitan después
de mí y lo hicieron en lo más profundo
de nuestras mentes los sudafricanos
sabemos que nuestro destino es estar
juntos game we know we belong to queda
este era su sueño de una nación arcoiris
un concepto que le hizo famoso diez años
después cuando el régimen del apartheid
había caído el presidente nelson mandela
lo puso al frente de la comisión de la
verdad y la reconciliación
pasó más de dos años escuchando
historias de encarcelamiento y tortura
tras superar un cáncer de próstata tutu
decidió salir de las fronteras de
sudáfrica para unirse a la lucha por la
justicia mundial resultó ser una ilusión
desde los campos de refugiados de sudán
del sur hasta la crisis postelectoral en
costa de márfil a lo largo de todos sus
viajes siguió siendo una activista por
la paz franco y a veces polémico atacó a
israel por el trato que da a los
palestinos calificándolo de apartheid
moderno pero su principal objetivo fue
el presidente sudafricano jacob zuma al
que acusó de corrupción en 2013 tutu
anunció que dejaría de votar al cn a el
partido gobernante que derribó el
apartheid palabras que llegarían a tener
sus consecuencias en diciembre de ese
año en nelson mandela murió a los 95
años mientras los líderes mundiales se
reunían para presentar sus últimos
respetos desmon tutú sólo tuvo dos
minutos para rendir homenaje a su viejo
amigo
podemos entonces devolverle la sonrisa a
dios banco a pesar de las terribles
historias de quienes se cruzaron en su
camino las sonrisas las risas y los
bailes de desmon tutú demostraron que
tenía una fe que podía poner fin a la
injusticia
[Aplausos]
uno de los primeros dirigentes
internacionales en reaccionar a la
muerte de tutu fue el primer ministro
británico boris johnson a través de su
cuenta de twitter se declaró
entristecido por la partida del
arzobispo
estoy profundamente entristecido por
escuchar de la muerte del arzobispo
desmond tutu él fue una figura crítica
en la lucha contra el apartheid y la
lucha para crear una nueva sudáfrica
será recordado por su espíritu de
liderazgo y su incontenible buen humor
en otras noticias este domingo se cumple
un mes desde que la organización mundial
de la salud declaró la variante omicron
de el coronavirus como preocupante desde
entonces esta se ha extendido desde
sudáfrica al resto del mundo y a pesar
de los avances en las investigaciones
todavía se desconoce cuál podría ser su
verdadero impacto hace un mes en la
nueva variante del coronavirus la de
punto 1.1 529 fue declarada como
preocupante por la ms hoy anunciamos al
ave punto 1.1 529 como variante
preocupante bajo el nombre de omicron
detectada por primera vez en sudáfrica y
conocida como un micrón su alta
transmisibilidad hizo saltar las alarmas
en los gobiernos a lo largo de todo el
mundo impulsando nuevos cierres de
fronteras y dejando en un principio
aislados a varios países del sur de
áfrica
impossible benson south africa la
imposición de prohibiciones de viaje a
sudáfrica y a una serie de países del
sur de áfrica son lamentables injustas y
poco científicas teniendo en cuenta que
fueron nuestros propios científicos
científicos africanos los primeros en
detectar la variante omicron affliction
sanches países como reino unido francia
e italia alcanzaron el récord de
contagios en cuestión de semanas
impulsando restricciones como el retorno
del porte de mascarillas en exterior en
españa hasta un estricto confinamiento
en países bajos pero es la variante un
micrón tan peligrosa como se cree los
primeros análisis sugieren que los casos
de omicron tienen un 15% menos de
probabilidades de acudir al hospital y
40% menos de probabilidades de ser
hospitalizados durante una noche o más
omicron es la variante que más
mutaciones acumula en su genoma y por
tanto la más contagiosa y aunque sus
efectos fueran más leves su alta
transmisibilidad pone en riesgo de
colapso a los sistemas de salud produce
síntomas similares a los catarro común
poca pérdida del olfato y más contagios
entre recuperados o vacunados ahora un
mes después de su denominación como
preocupante las investigaciones siguen
pero en este panorama la buena noticia
es que sus efectos sobre el mundo actual
son mucho menores gracias a la
combinación de la vacunación las
defensas naturales por los contagios
previos de kobe 19 y la posible levedad
del virus los científicos sin embargo
siguen recomendando la prudencia
luego de que por primera vez desde el
inicio de la pandemia se registrarán más
de 100.000 nuevos contagios en francia
en un día el presidente de emanuel
mccomb convocó a un consejo de salud de
emergencia para analizar la respuesta a
la variante omicron la reunión se
realizará antes del encuentro del
consejo de ministros en el que se
discutirá el renovado pase sanitario que
estipularía que los franceses deban
presentar una prueba de vacunación para
acceder a restaurantes eventos y hasta
el transporte público si es aprobado por
el parlamento entrará en vigor el 15 de
enero andrés granadillo nos cuenta más
francia busca frenar a la variante
omicron el presidente manuel macrón
realiza este lunes un consejo de
ministros con el que busca aprobar un
proyecto para un nuevo pase de
vacunación el texto transforma el pase
sanitario actual y busca que sea
presentado para acceder a actividades de
ocio restaurantes bares ferias y
transporte público internacional si lo
aprueba la asamblea nacional el pase
entrará en vigencia el 15 de enero la
presentación de una prueba negativa de
kobe 19 seguirá siendo válida para
acceder a establecimientos y servicios
de salud
la medida intenta hacer frente al
repunte de kobe 19 los nuevos contagios
siguen disparados por lo que las
restricciones aumentan ahora se exige el
uso de mascarillas para los mayores de
11 años incluso al aire libre en lugares
con más de 10 personas mientras la
vacunación va a buen ritmo en 24 horas
se registraron casi 600.000 dosis la
mayoría de ellas de refuerzo según datos
del ministerio de salud entre millones
de personas en francia se han aplicado
tres dosis de la vacuna
prácticamente un tercio de la población
total del país desde el miércoles además
está abierta la vacunación a menores de
5 a 11 años
la junta militar sudanesa informó que 58
policías resultaron heridos en medio de
las multitudinarias protestas
registradas el sábado contra el golpe de
estado asimismo señaló que 114 civiles
fueron arrestados se enfrentarán
acciones penales durante la movilización
los militares cortaron las
comunicaciones y lanzaron gases
lacrimógenos contra los manifestantes
dejando casi 180 heridos durante la
jornada 48 personas han perdido la vida
en medio de la represión de las
protestas desde el golpe de estado del
25 de octubre
en burkina faso el gobierno decretó dos
jornadas de duelo por los 41 fallecidos
de un ataque terrorista perpetrado el
jueves contra un convoy de integrantes
de una milicia de lucha contra el
yihadismo las víctimas formaban parte
del grupo conocido como voluntarios por
la defensa de la patria es decir civiles
que participan en la lucha contra los
grupos yihadistas en colaboración con
las fuerzas armadas burguesas el
atentado ocurrió en la localidad de joe
en el norte del país y entre los
fallecidos está el líder de la
organización
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
noticias les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a ampliar toda la
información en france 24 punto com
[Música]